forged by the darkest whims of powers
Beyond reality
scp-682's body was a temple to All
Things feared by Mortals with extreme
regenerative abilities unparalleled
adaptive power and formidable features
that surpass any non-anomalous apex
predator and the vast majority of
anomalous ones and yet on level 32 of
the back rooms 682 has now been
separated from its indestructible Body
by it possibly even stronger being the
powerful backrooms entity known as
skeleton Queen who rules levels 32 with
a bony fist has exerted the power of her
domain and has disembodied the soul of
682 rendering the malicious reptile or
rather its Spirit completely helpless
nobody would be coming to save 682's
soul from its current predicament of
course 682 was not the kind to rely on
others and was more surprised by the
fact that it had a mortal Soul the
closest thing to an all-powerful God in
the front rooms
scp-343 was recorded as being unable to
even interact with 682 a fact that the
reptile itself was only later made aware
of because it likewise could not
perceive 343 the notion of residing as a
your Consciousness in either heaven or
hell should they exist was never
something sick City too believed had a
chance of happening as if my existence
would ever be extinguished anyway the
rules of the back rooms were mysterious
and different from 682's native reality
so it was possible that the Labyrinthian
Dimensions to find what a soul was in a
different way but there was a second
option that 682 was considering not in
the Forefront of its mind but deep down
in the place of vulnerability which it
had become more in touch with as it
traveled in the back rooms that second
option was the possibility that the sum
total of 682's experiences in the back
rooms had somehow imbued the creature
with a soul or ignited the dormant spark
of its Soul causing it to grow to full
size like a spectral flame surely the
fact that there was some Essence to its
current form a self that existed outside
of the confines of its monstrous
physical shape was proof enough that 682
had become or always was more than the
sum of its creature Parts I will not be
anyone's Pawn to manipulate I have a
soul that belongs to myself alone
that knowledge alone kept 682 from
surrendering to its fate as the skeleton
Queen's plaything ever since it had
escaped the foundation its goal had been
to maintain that unassailable freedom
like the old AI that it once befriended
in its native reality 682 was now
thoroughly convinced that it was not
merely a machine but instead of Free
Will being with a right to exist outside
of containment the once undefeated Beast
would reclaim its record no matter what
it took it refused to turn away its
future potential by becoming a permanent
resident of the forest of the skeleton
Queen The Entity herself was still in
her larger more imposing form she
carried 682's Soul deeper into the
forest leaving her tree Warriors to
Devour the reptiles abandoned physical
body 682 knew better than to attempt to
converse with the skeleton queen as she
seemed to be mute possibly by choice it
chose instead to keep its mind active
searching for an opening to make an
escape the queen soon found a skeleton
floating amongst the branches which
unlike most of the others didn't have
glowing eyes
with a single graceful motion of her
hand she placed the spectral fire of
682's Soul inside the skull of the
floating skeleton in a Flash 682 found
its Consciousness inside of a new body
the skeleton itself this wasn't an ideal
form compared to what 682 was used to
but it could feel that Mobility was
possible in these skeleton Limbs and
that was a far cry from being a
disembodied spirit this body is weak but
it will have to do now I must bide my
time for that opening 682 the skeleton
remained almost motionless as the
skeleton queen admired her new
acquisition a few moments later she
shrank back to her more humanoid form
and danced away into the world 682 now
had the Glade to itself and it
remembered well where its former body
had been left once the skeleton Queen
was completely out of view skeleton 682
leaped down from its Heights of the
trees and landed on the ground it took
off running towards the place where its
Soul had been removed planning to
assimilate itself back into its old body
I have to become myself again then that
disgusting skeleton Queen will regret
crossing my path as if responding to six
City two's thoughts of Revenge the
skeleton Queen danced back into its path
skeleton 682 froze in place and was
caught off guard as the skeleton Queen
snapped her fingers and caused several
more skeletons to fall from the upper
branches all at once the skeletons began
to dance not knowing another way to move
past in its current form 682's Soul made
the skeleton body it was inhabiting
begin to dance this caused the skeleton
Queen to make the first vocalization
that 682 had heard her make a deep
feminine laugh she extended her hands
and took hold of the skeleton that
housed 682's Soul leading it into a
ballroom dance 682 bitterly mumbled
about this whole thing being humiliating
ah so he can speak said the skeleton
Queen what an interesting Soul you are
682 was not expecting the skeleton Queen
to sound so human but considering that
the rulers of other levels at 682
visited were also capable of speech her
attempts to communicate were a sign that
she was not as different from the other
backroom's entities as she might have
seemed for now she wasn't in her most
monstrous form and that meant she didn't
feel threatened and in that state of
blissful ignorance was exactly exactly
where 682 wanted her 682 when this new
skeleton form protested that his soul
was not of this Dimension he was a
powerful being from another Universe one
that should not be messed with the queen
smiled to her 682 Soul was no different
from any of the others that she'd
captured in her skeleton-filled
playground naturally 682 found being
compared to other beings disgusting and
insulting again the queen was merely
amused she said I witnessed the plight
of lost goblings fell beasts and The
Brood spawn of the outer darkness and
its many incarnations this forest and my
power over it are immune to the stain of
Scarlet here there is only room for
black and white 682 chuckled in its
skeleton frame so was the Scotland Queen
the true ruler of the back rooms you
still don't get it there are no
backgrounds nothing
the queen had started to become a bit
more ominous in her tone 682 almost
missed the timber of humanity that was
once there she went on describing in
detail she couldn't know every step of
the journey that brought 682 to this
place she spoke of the close bond that
682 had formed with entity 7 Jerry of
the places of Tranquility that made sick
City to feel something close to
happiness and of the victories against
all the Hostile entities at 682 had
bested she described it as a dream or a
poem a fleeting and Beautiful Eulogy for
a soul now freed of all obligations
freed from purpose freed from Life 682
watched as the body had hoped to return
to was pulled deep beneath the surface
of the forest the skeleton Queen
continued to lead her skeletons in dance
it was a dance of surrender a loss of
the inevitable Doom of All Souls 682 was
starting to forget which skeleton its
Soul was even inside of anymore anger
began to coarse through what remained of
scp-682's Consciousness this cannot be
How I Meet My Demise I will not face
such a disgusting fate and then just
then it all clicked 682 realized that
its Soul wasn't inside any of the
skeletons at all because it had been
lying dormant somewhere else somewhere
far more expected the skeleton Queen
hadn't ripped out the essence of its
Spirit but instead had fallen for a
trick that even this piece of 682's
Consciousness hadn't known about
of course as if I could have a soul
beneath the Earth of the woods
scp-682's reptilian body began to stir
it was now connected to the soul that
dwelled within the skeleton Queen's
Forest a soul created through the heart
to destroy reptiles indomitable ability
to adapt to any and we do mean any
adverse circumstance its powers of
adaptation went beyond the physical and
into even the metaphysical it could for
lack of a better description forcibly
evolve it's
well the skeleton Queen was capable of
manipulating The Souls of human
explorers controlling the entirety of
682's Mind was far beyond her
capabilities so in response to her
Supernatural curse that removes Souls
682 broke off a tiny piece of its
Consciousness to serve as a decoy or
more accurately a parasite that was
slowly infecting level 32 The Forest of
the skeleton Queen and now was the real
opening for 682 to overcome the control
of the latest backrooms entity to
believe that it was up to the challenge
of destroying the hard to destroy
reptile 682 gloated that the skeleton
Queen had never truly known what it was
up against the dance of the skeletons
ceased as the queen became aware of
Rumblings of 682's original body digging
its way back towards the surface I am
not simply another child of the Scarlet
King I am more than my bloodline more
than whatever destiny he was chosen for
me I am a greater threat than even the
foundation knew but you'll know the
monster that was as cp682 emerged from
the ground biting into the skeleton
Queen and immobilizing her one skeleton
stepped forth approaching the queen then
another and soon all of them 682 was now
in control of the skeleton Queen's
entire realm the soul decoy having
fulfilled its purpose skeleton Queen 682
said through the body of a skeleton a
part of me thought you really could have
been the one to bring me down but I have
to thank you because now you have shown
me the truth of the back rooms and the
truth is anything can be the back rooms
skeleton Queen cried out in pain as
682's Jaws sunk deeper into her she
tried to take her intimidating monster
form but even that was not enough for
pry herself free from the reptile's
grasp in your memory I will become the
thing that I once hated I will become
the back rooms as it spoke those words
682's adaptation Advanced to an entirely
new level as it had demonstrated in so
many cross-tests 682 devoured and
assimilated the properties of the threat
it was currently facing in a moment of
sheer willpower and freakish resilience
682 absorbed the skeleton Queen and her
huge force of skeletons into its body
level 32 buckled and warped under the
command of a new master hostile entities
from every level felt a terrifying
disturbance in the back rooms as one of
the great level rulers was toppled at
the same time 682's perception of the
back rooms changed dramatically and
rapidly it found itself on level zero
once more clearing through entity after
entity in a vengeful Stampede then
minutes later it was cycling through
every level at incredible speed drawing
in the essence of the back rooms itself
and becoming something greater than
either
scp-682 or the back room when the great
shift in the liminal Abyss subsided 682
had taken its most powerful form yet its
reptilian bodies still existed but its
Soul or at least what had become of the
Soul fragment it had created had
expanded into a wholly new level of the
back rooms an amalgamation of every
level that 682 had ever touched welcome
to level
682 the hard to destroy reptile was now
more than an entity dwelling within the
Sea of altered realities it had become
an irrevocable element of the back rooms
a being that would soon be feared as a
master among the dimension rulers of
many worlds but it did have plenty more
levels to conquer first now go check out
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms at scp-682 makes friends in back
rooms for more